if i can start with a quite a broad
question do you accept as
as those we interviewed in jared's
report have pointed out that there have
been
once again mixed messages but this time
around june
july the 19th i mean is it a return to
normality or not
it's about getting the balance right so
we've been clear we delayed for four
weeks
uh the step four which has enabled us to
strengthen that vaccine wall an
additional seven
million vaccines have been delivered in
that time
but there's no perfect time to start
reopening and that's what the prime
minister the chief medical officer
chief scientific advisor were clear on
yesterday
so what we're doing is we're reopening
with the summer holidays with the summer
weather
that is seen as the best time to do so
we are going to have to live
with the virus and return to normal
but at the same time be cautious and
that's the balance that the prime
minister was striking yesterday
but according to the government's own
scientists the consequence
of opening up on july the 19th is and
there
and estimates vary but perhaps as high
as 200 deaths a day
i mean is that an acceptable price for
reopening well what they also said is
there is no perfect time
and actually reopening when the schools
are back in september reopening when
the colder weather is also bringing
other challenges
also brings its risk so there's no
perfect time to do this
what we've done is deploy the vaccine an
extra seven million
opening when the schools are going to be
shut is seen as the optimum time
to do so but it's about getting that
balance right so people
reaching their own judgments being
sensible following the guidance
but we also need to get back to normal
businesses need to to fire up we need to
get the economy going
and those are important as well because
there are consequences to not doing that
both economically and in terms of
people's health of course there are of
course there are but but again
to return to the original question in
terms of mixed messaging
we have been told a variety of things
that now seem rather shaky for example
the idea that this pathway out of
lockdown is is irreversible
and boris johnson said back in downing
street and until end of february we will
not go back
we are now traveling on a one-way road
to freedom i mean that that's wrong
isn't it that's just simply not correct
we could see restrictions being
reapplied later on in the year
well i think the the message has been
very clear throughout which is the
vaccine is the key people need to get
their jobs
people have responsibilities let's clear
this up is it reversible or not well we
have taken the cautious of the prime
minister addressed this at the press
conference yesterday we've been cautious
in order uh to seek for it to be
irreversible but one never knows
uh you know what he did back in february
when he said we will not go back we are
now traveling
the vaccine has provided that wall an
extra seven million
uh vaccines have been delivered as a
result of the extra four weeks
and that's why we've taken that extra
time but we need to learn to live
with the virus we need to get those
businesses open some business has been
closed
for 16 months so it's right we get the
economy moving in that way
and learn to live with the virus but the
key throughout and our message has been
consistent
that the vaccine is key your viewers
have responded
that's perhaps the one thing the
government has been consistent on that
the vaccine is key to all of this let's
talk about vaccine passports again
nadeem sahibwi back in february we're
not planning to have a passport in the
uk
michael gove on this program will i need
one to go to large sporting events no
passports that's not being planned and
yesterday we again hear from the prime
minister backtracking
that these businesses you know perhaps
which will have large crowds within them
should be using them as a matter of
social responsibility
well i mean if you're saying is this
unprecedented is this complex
is this challenging has the government
have our scientists
been learning about the virus as we went
through we saw that before christmas
when the kent variant came along we had
to change our plans of course we
followed the data
and we've changed our plans if the data
has required that
we've followed the science throughout
but it's been complex it's been
unprecedented i think your viewers
appreciate that but they also recognize
that the vaccine is the way through this
we have deployed that two-thirds of the
adult population now having their two
jobs
um so the vaccine is the way forward but
we also need to live with
this condition and and get the economy
moving again sure
i will note however in the space of
about a week and a half the emphasis
being placed in all of this by the
government has changed entirely from you
know
ministers referring to it as freedom day
on this program
it's now softly softly be as cautious as
we can i mean just in terms of masks
and we had robert generic on the fourth
of july saying people need to take
personal responsibility
you had your boss at the treasury saying
that he was going to stop wearing them
as soon as the requirement was
was dropped now we're being told that
being wearing masks is to be encouraged
in some settings
i mean where does the consistency i
think people are grown up they
understand
that many people are frustrated with
wearing masks it's not particularly
pleasant experience if for example
you're on a long train journey
and if the carriage is empty uh then
people quite rightly then say well
is it necessary and that's what step
four and the vaccine enables us
to get rid of but at the same time if
you're on a very busy
commuter tube for example if you're with
people you don't frequently meet
what the guidance is saying is then it's
prudent to wear a mask but what we've
changed is the
legal requirement so we're saying it's
no longer the law to do so
but let's trust your viewers to reach
their judgment when it's crowded when
it's busy
of course we're a matter of two days ago
judgment
two days after july the 19th there will
be a session of prime minister's
questions in which
social distancing requirements in the
chamber will be removed you will be
cheated by gel with your colleagues
there is no
mandatory requirement for people to wear
face masks in the chamber and one must
suspect given what we've heard from
colleagues within your party that some
people will not be wearing them
i mean two days after the country's told
you know let's
stagger returning to work let's wear
masks when you're in crowded places
we're going to see politicians doing the
entire opposite
again i think it's right that parliament
uh the national pilot comes back
together we
we get that working as it should it
enables the government to be scrutinized
effectively it's for the speaker uh not
for members of the government to decide
what the rules are
that apply uh in the chamber but what
the guidance has said and what the chief
medical officer was very clear in the
press conference yesterday
is that people will form their judgments
in terms of when it's crowded
as to what is appropriate and i think
your viewers will get that we're
trusting british people
rather than making it a legal
requirement today
you cannot see what happened at wembley
way at the weekend there was no social
distancing
no one was wearing any masks those are
the people that you're asking to show
some personal responsibility
those are the people you're asking to
show some common sense you know if we've
got england fans
sticking flares up their backside it
does seem a bit of a
it does seem a bit of a stretch to say
that they're going to be taking the
personal response
i think when we're sharing exceptional
cases like that individual i don't think
is where
the british public are in terms of that
we're not winning well i think there
were some people hugely regrettably and
the wembley authorities were reviewing
those who broke into the stadium but
again i think we're talking about a very
small number
of people in a particular circumstance
so that is not the norm of the british
people
and the british people i think will
understand the distinction between the
legal requirement to wear mass
which has been the position up to this
point and as we learn to live with this
virus
as we move to step four as we benefit
from the british public responding
in the way they have to taking up the
vaccine that allows us to free up
uh the legal requirement and have
guidance and people will form their
judgment if they're meeting people who
are not from their usual family group
their friendship group
they're meeting people in a very crowded
place they will have the option then to
wear a mask
and that is what the gardeners will
recommend but but as the racism
directed at the players you know on the
pitch inside wembley demonstrates the
actions of a small minority
can have a huge impact i just want to
focus a little bit on the racism
that the footballers have have
experienced tyron mings
wrote this on twitter last night you
don't get to stoke the fire at the
beginning of the tournament by labeling
our anti-racism messages gesture
politics
and then pretend to be disgusted when
the very thing we're campaigning against
happens that's an england footballer a
black england footballer
laying some of the blame for the racism
that he and his colleagues experienced
at the door of your party at the door of
your home secretary well i
completely condemn the racism that those
footballers have suffered i think
the country at large does and has been
shot by it and that's why the government
is taking action through the online
harms bill the culture secretary
as you know has been meeting with senior
black footballers
uh working with them to ensure that the
the companies that provide the platforms
for this racist abuse are we're bringing
legislation
forward to do that what has been taken
against natalie elfic
your colleague within the party who sent
a message to the conservatives whatapp
group
they lost would it be ungenerous to
suggest rashford should have spent more
time
perfecting his game and less time
playing politics i mean what does it say
about the state of your party
that she felt comfortable sending that
message to our colleagues well that
message was wrong and natalie has
apologized
for it but we're taking action to tackle
at this
through the online homes bill and
that is what needs to happen we need to
ensure that those platforms
take action and if they don't the
government will take action against them
i have often quoted the prime minister
to government ministers on occasion such
as this his comments about
pikanini's with watermelon smiles the
problem with africa is that we're not in
charge anymore
his comments about muslim women looking
about like letterboxes and the response
is always
that they need to be viewed in context
but isn't the context that those remarks
now need to be seen in
is that the dog's abuse that has been
thrown against
black english footballers simply because
they missed a penalty kick
isn't that the context in which we need
to view those remarks now no we need to
condemn those remarks
uh against the footballers the the the
racism that they've suffered is
completely
unacceptable that is why uh we are
taking action
in terms of the online's harm bill and
that is why the platforms
that provide the opportunity for people
to make those remarks
themselves need to take urgent action
we've been very clear on that the
culture secretary
has been working with the fa uh with
leading footballers
uh to ensure action is taken is
completely unacceptable
and we are acting on it why on earth
would the prime minister and the home
secretary
choose not to condemn fans who were
booing players who took the knee it's a
gesture that they have made perfectly
clear
from the start of the tournament it's
not about black lives matter but it was
about them
making a stand against racism racism
that we've just seen clearly demonstrate
in the past 48 hours well the home
secretary has repeatedly taken
a stand against races which she herself
has been subject to
with respect the home secretary herself
has been the subject
of appalling online racist abuse
she herself has been on the receiving
end of this
she has consistently condemned racist
abuse
online and she is taking action as home
secretary
against some of the extreme right-wing
groups that are responsible
for this so she is using her office to
take action to clump down on it
but she herself has suffered from it she
understands it and she is acting on it
steve